Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
« Derrière chaque grand homme
se cache une femme. »
Beau proverbe.
C’est bien de reconnaître
que des femmes ont soutenu et aidé
à la carrière des grands hommes.
Mais qui sont-elles ?
Qui sont ces femmes
puissantes et inspirantes ?
Et savez-vous qu’elles ont aussi
apporté leur pierre à l’édifice ?
On ne vous l’a pas dit ?
À y regarder de plus près,
ce proverbe est une arnaque.
Il donne l’impression d’accorder
de l’importance aux femmes
et de réparer une injustice
mais les hommes restent les modèles
et les femmes aux oubliettes.
Si je vous dis,
Mileva Marić.
Ça ne vous dit rien ?
Mais vous connaissez
certainement son mari.
Le génie du siècle,
rendu célèbre par sa formule E=mc2,
Oui, Albert Einstein
et sa tignasse ébouriffée
ne vous aura pas échappé.
Quant à sa femme,
elle est passée à la trappe.
Pourtant, Mileva Marić était
une brillante mathématicienne.
Bien meilleure que son mari,
d’ailleurs qui disait toujours :
« J’ai besoin de ma femme.
Elle résout pour moi tous
mes problèmes mathématiques. »
D’ailleurs, sans elle, pas certain
qu’il serait parvenu à découvrir
sa fameuse loi sur la relativité.
Elle était de toutes ses recherches.
Mais Mileva Marić est morte dans la misère
et sans la moindre reconnaissance.
Reconnaissance et gratitude n’ont,
hélas, de féminin que les mots.
Et le monde des sciences
en est un des pires exemples.
A l’exception notoire de Marie Curie
qui s’est vu décerner deux prix Nobel.
Mais ne vous y trompez pas,
c’est l’exception qui confirme la règle.
Car si les génies de la science
n’ont pas réussi à trouver la formule
qui rend les corps invisibles,
ils ont superbement réussi
à rendre les femmes invisibles.
Je peux vous citer plein de
grandes femmes scientifiques.
Esther Lederberg, fameuse microbiologiste.
Rosalind Franklin,
grande biologiste moléculaire.
Jocelyn Bell, brillante astrophysicienne.
Lise Meitner qui a découvert
la fission nucléaire.
Elles ont toutes fait
des découvertes extraordinaires.
Mais vous savez quoi ?
C’est à leur mari ou aux hommes
avec lesquels elles travaillaient
à qui l’on a décerné les prix
Nobel qu’elles méritaient.
En fait, la spoliation des femmes,
c’est une mécanique
scientifiquement prouvée.
Le phénomène est tellement répandu
qu’il porte désormais un nom.
C’est l’effet Matilda.
Mais au fond, vous aussi,
vous avez été spoliés.
Car une histoire qui oublie
ces femmes géniales
nous prive de brillants modèles.
Citez-moi des femmes qui ont
marqué l’histoire de France.
Jeanne d’Arc
pour nous avoir sauvés des Anglais.
Marie Curie, côté sciences.
L’exception qui confirme la règle.
Marie Curie, cela dit en passant,
qui a été la première
à entrer au Panthéon.
C’était en 1995.
Aujourd’hui, elles sont six,
six femmes à être admises
au Temple de la nation
sur plus de 70 locataires.
C’est comme ça.
Partout dans le monde,
l’Histoire a oublié les femmes.
Ok, à l’époque, il n’y avait pas TikTok
ou Instagram pour se faire connaître.
Il n’empêche, l’Histoire
n’a pas fait son boulot
car dans tous les domaines de la société,
politique, économique ou social,
des grandes femmes ont marqué leur époque.
Il y en a même qui ont
régné sur des empires.
En Chine, un pays qui
n’est pas forcément réputé
pour son ouverture envers les femmes.
Eh bien, au VIIᵉ siècle,
c’est l’impératrice Wu Zetian,
une souveraine éclairée qui
a régné sur l’Empire du Milieu.
Et puis, il y a Roxelane
dans l’Empire ottoman
qui a assumé la fonction
d’un souverain absent.
Sacrée bonne femme, Roxelane.
D’esclave au harem d’Istanbul,
elle est devenue sultane.
Mais finalement, l'histoire ne retient
que sa romance avec le sultan.
Même Cléopâtre a son image écornée.
C’était une grande reine d’Égypte,
Cléopâtre.
Mais elle est souvent réduite
à son idylle avec Jules César,
à son nez ou à son maquillage.
C’est sûr, s’il y avait eu TikTok
à l’époque, elle aurait cartonné.
C'est un fait, le temps s'est échiné
à minimiser l'influence des femmes.
Pourtant, aux États-Unis,
lorsque le Président Wilson
tombe gravement malade,
c’est son épouse qui va jouer
la doublure du président.
C'est elle qui va assumer
la fonction suprême.
Oui, c’est Edith Wilson qui,
dans le plus grand secret,
a tenu les rênes de
la première puissance mondiale.
Mais bien entendu, l’histoire
ne retient que l’œuvre du Président.
Quelle que soit
leur fonction ou leurs talents,
l’histoire s’est échinée
à minimiser l’influence des femmes.
Dans le monde de l’art,
à force d’obstination et d’ambition,
des femmes sont parvenues à leur but.
Comme la fameuse sculptrice
Camille Claudel
ou la peintre Berthe Morisot.
Ok, elles ont galéré, surtout Camille.
Il n’empêche, elles ont réussi
à s’affranchir des règles
pour continuer à exercer leur art.
Il y a même Rosa Bonheur qui
était une grande peintre animalière
et qui a réussi à s’imposer
dans un milieu très masculin.
Rosa Bonheur se fichait bien
des règles sociales de l’époque.
Tandis que d’autres
femmes se sont sacrifiées
par amour pour l’homme qu’elles aimaient.
Alma Mahler, compositrice de renom,
rêvait d’écrire un opéra.
Mais son époux Gustav Mahler,
quand il décide de l’épouser,
exige d’elle qu’elle renonce
à toute velléité personnelle.
Par amour, elle accepte.
Vous savez ce qu’il lui a sorti
le jour des épousailles ?
« Tu n’as désormais qu’une seule
profession, me rendre heureux. »
Dans son genre, André Malraux empêchait
sa femme Clara Malraux,
pourtant bourrée de talent,
de devenir écrivain comme lui.
Son argument ?
« Il vaut mieux être ma femme
qu’un écrivain de seconde zone. »
André Malraux, auteur de
« La Condition humaine ».
Grand homme.
Désolé, vous ne le lirez
plus jamais comme avant.
Il y a plein de femmes qui
se sont sacrifiées par amour.
Encore aujourd’hui, des femmes
brillantes et talentueuses
se mettent en retrait
professionnel au seul motif
que la priorité est donnée à leur mari.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que qui va s’occuper des enfants ?
Cette petite phrase a
été prononcée en 2007
au sein de la classe politique.
C’était il n’y a pas si longtemps que ça.
Elle en dit long sur
la pression du carcan familial.
On est au XXIᵉ siècle, bordel !
Alors, ne vous oubliez pas.
Osez revendiquer votre talent
et sortir de l’ombre d’un boss
qui se réserve toute la lumière
ou d’un époux qui prend toute la place.
Soyez libres.
Et ne les oubliez pas.
Inspirez-vous de ces femmes qui ont
osé aller jusqu’au bout de leurs rêves.
On a tous des rêves.
Plus jeune, je rêvais d’aventure.
Je voulais devenir journaliste
et être reporter de guerre.
Ce n’est pas toujours simple
d’évoluer dans un milieu d’hommes
sévèrement testostéronés.
Il faut s'accrocher.
Je me suis accrochée justement
à deux femmes géniales
chez qui j’ai puisé
l’inspiration et l’énergie
et beaucoup plus encore.
Lee Miller et Gerda Taro sont
des sacrés modèles pour moi.
Lee Miller d’abord,
que l’histoire voudrait réduire
à l’icône des surréalistes,
était bien plus que ça.
C’était une artiste à part entière.
Mannequin, photographe, Paris, New York,
plusieurs maris, des amants,
curieuse de tout.
Lee Miller a eu mille vies
dont celle de reporter de guerre.
Et son audace n'avait pas de limites.
En 1940, quand la Seconde
Guerre mondiale éclate,
elle réussit à convaincre,
contre vents et marées,
de se faire recruter par le magazine Vogue
pour lequel elle posait.
Elle réussit à se faire recruter
comme photo-reporter.
Elle part sur la ligne
de front en Normandie
et pousse jusqu’à la reddition
des Allemands à Saint-Malo.
À la libération des camps, c’est la seule
femme parmi les reporters sur place.
Ses photos sont exceptionnelles.
Elles ont une patte, la sienne.
Lee Miller a osé aller sur un terrain
qui ne lui était pourtant pas destiné,
surtout à cette époque,
et elle a réussi.
Elle m’a poussée, moi aussi,
à aller sur un terrain
qui ne m’était pas acquis
en tant que femme.
Et c’est son courage que je suis
allée chercher en 2003 à Bagdad,
lorsque j’ai couvert mon premier conflit.
Ce courage, je l’ai puisé
chez une autre femme,
une autre photo-reporter
exceptionnelle, Gerda Taro.
Elle m’a influencée à
un moment de ma carrière
où je pensais que
j’allais devoir renoncer.
En effet, quand je suis
rentrée d’Irak en 2003,
où j’avais bien fait le job pour une
grande chaîne de télévision française,
mes collègues masculins et
patrons d’agence m’ont prévenue :
« Tu sais Patricia, reporter de guerre,
ce n’est pas facile pour les femmes.
D’ailleurs, ce n’est pas pour les femmes.
Tu finiras seule et tu passeras
à côté d’une vie de famille.
Et puis, y aller une fois
à la guerre, c’est une chose.
Y retourner, c’est compliqué
pour les femmes.
Faut être costaud.
Vous les femmes,
vous n’avez pas la même sensibilité.
Et puis, c’est aussi
une question de nerfs. »
Une question de nerfs chez les femmes...
Ouais.
C’est plutôt une question
d’ego chez les mecs.
Craignent-ils la concurrence ?
Évidemment.
D’ailleurs, le fameux photographe,
Robert Capa,
ne s’est pas gêné.
Pour éviter que sa compagne
Gerda Taro ne lui fasse de l’ombre,
il a carrément gommé son nom
au dos des photos qu’il publiait.
En effet, en 36,
quand la guerre d’Espagne éclate,
Gerda Taro, intrépide et courageuse,
décide de suivre son mari,
Robert Capa, sur la ligne de front.
Leurs photos étaient mélangées
et toutes signées de l’atelier Capa.
Gerda Taro est morte sur le front.
Elle avait 27 ans seulement.
Et pas de famille en France
pour gérer son patrimoine.
Il aura fallu attendre 80 ans et 2008
pour découvrir tous les clichés qu’elle
avait réalisés et reconnaître son talent.
Pas moins de 800 photos remarquables
de la guerre d’Espagne.
Alors, merci qui ?
Merci Gerda.
Au fond, grâce à elles,
j’ai trouvé ma place, moi aussi.
Et j’y suis retournée en Irak,
en Syrie, en Afghanistan
et leur courage ne m’a jamais quittée.
Croyez-moi quand on connaît
ces femmes extraordinaires
qui ont osé aller
jusqu’au bout de leur passion,
on se sent pousser des ailes.
Quand on sait que depuis l’enfance,
on évolue à travers des modèles,
l’histoire ne nous offre que
des grandes figures masculines.
En ce qui me concerne, j’ai du mal
à m’identifier à De Gaulle, Jules César.
Non, ce n’est pas
qu’une question de taille.
Napoléon, je ne m'y retrouve pas non plus.
Je me retrouve chez ces femmes,
ces femmes géniales,
ces femmes remarquables
que l’Histoire a pourtant effacées.
Au fond, elles m’ont aidée
dans ma carrière.
Elles m’ont aidée
à devenir cette journaliste
libre, courageuse et tenace.
Alors, peut-être que l’une d’entre
elles sera un modèle pour vous.
C'est vrai, la société évolue.
La reconnaissance des femmes
est devenue un enjeu sociétal
à l’heure où elles se battent
toujours pour leur juste place.
Et il y a même des hommes qui
partagent la vie de femmes célèbres
sans en revendiquer la lumière.
Qui est le mari d’Angela Merkel ?
Et qui se cachait derrière
la grande Simone Veil ?
En ce qui me concerne, aucun homme
n’a voulu vivre dans mon ombre.
En réalité, je n’aimerais pas
qu’un homme reste dans les coulisses
parce que nous, les femmes,
on recherche l’alter ego
avec qui grandir et partager la lumière.
Alors gageons qu’à l’avenir, on dira :
« À côté de chaque grande femme,
il y a un homme. »
(Applaudissements)